culture co-chair of pi data billing and
we have here also tia
and valentina from the phi data building
team
um as far as i can see
maybe some others um
um yes we are the building chapter of pi
data
and pi data as some of you may have
heard before is dinam
is the educational program of non-focus
and we will talk about we it will be
introduced
very soon our program for today
is me i am your introduction happening
now
and then we have two very cool thoughts
um one
is from katya fro flores
puzzle we'll talk about um
controlling many satellites at the same
time
and then we we will have the second talk
from niladri
check her dude about deep fake
and why he has trust issues um let's
hope he can solve them for some
um yeah some of them today
in between we will have a five-minute
break and
at the end we can all meet up in this
nice platform called
wonder it's kind of a spatial
chat thingy similar together town where
you can walk on your screen and talk in
smaller groups and chat
and later we will post in the chat the
link so we can all
gather there later
this meetup is recorded so both
talks are recorded and are also streamed
now in youtube so please take it into
consideration
um for both talks if you have any
questions please write them down in the
chat
and we will pass them on for the speaker
at the end of the day
of their talk also if you are watching
on youtube you can also
write down the questions in the youtube
chat and we will pass them on to the
speaker
so yeah as i mentioned we are pi data
building we are the local
chapter of pi data which is kind of a
worldwide thing
we started in 2016 and we had
quite a lot of fun meetups and
conferences every
uh ever since we are announcing it up
every third wednesday of the month you
probably found us on meetup.org and you
can just register and come to all of our
meetups
um sometimes these questions come
up we are all volunteers here so doing
it not clear why but yeah no one pays
for that
um we have a code of conduct which is
the non-focus code of contact
in short be kind to each other and
please remember that the code of conduct
applies also when we are online
um yeah and if you are in berlin
and you are interested in python and you
like and you would like to contact
and get in touch with other people who
are interested in python you're
welcome to join the python building
stack um there's also
a data science channel
um that you can follow and also handling
their job posts there or you can ask
technical problems
um yeah so we're gonna start now with
the first talk
um this is us by databellin you can
follow us on twitter
and this is our website
i will stop the show now it is sharing
the screen
and i think valentina will introduce our
first speaker
yeah hi everyone i'm valentina also
co-organizer of pi data
i have the pleasure to introduce my
colleague
katya um who will be speaking about
uh how planet operates more than 100
satellites using using agile aerospace
katya is the lead of the space
operations team for planet
um and she has a background in
telecommunication engineering but also a
passion for space
and uh she has been working in the space
operations for the last
seven years so she's been scaling
operations
from starting for from five satellites
to more than 300 saturn lights
launched to date so
katya welcome
thanks valentina and thanks to pi data
for having me
um so let me
share my screen
all right yeah
so um i'm gonna talk today
through what does it mean to operate
satellites and then what does it mean to
operate
uh hundreds of them um so
yeah as valentina mentioned i'm the team
lead of the space operations
uh group of planets so we are actually a
small team of people less than 10.
um i just i want to start
with like with showing you what does the
constellation that we operate look like
i think
visual way is the best way to um
thanks right um so this is a
day in the life of the dove so we call
our satellites doves
um because they remind remind us to that
they have two wings uh
so yeah we just we call them doves and
then a group of satellites we will call
them flocks
so basically what our sites are doing
they are taking uh their earth sensing
um their remote sensing satellites so
they are taking pictures
of our earth continuously um exactly as
the simulation shows so um they are
acting like a line scanner so it's like
having
multiple cameras on the same plane
different planes
um just doing that taking images of
landmass as they pass over the
the earth and having that constellation
on the space allows us to take
daily images of the entire landmass of
the earth and by having all that data
then we are able to
inform decision makers and provide um
the visibility on the changes that
happen on the day-to-day that
uh weren't there available before
um all right so i wanna give you a quick
overview to what
a constellation of satellites look like
um so
we had actually three types of
satellites um
so i when i started working on space
operations um
i was working with the rapid eye
constellation
so those are five satellites the size of
a fridge
um and they were launched on 2008 and
they have been taking images
uh up to 2020 so last year
so we have this huge archive of data um
for all these years from this
constellation and of course um
even though they were designed to last
six to seven years they
ought to grow that that period of time
so they continue taking images even
years after
but it reaches a point where um you know
there's such degradation that we
we wanted to make sure that we had the
capability of
lowering their orbit so that they could
be safely
safe safely re-enter the atmosphere
within a
uh a time that is responsible
um and then then we have the doves
and superdogs so we have two generations
of satellites and that's why we call
them super dope superlofts are the last
latest iteration of our sets
um so we have launched to date uh more
than 300 of these and we currently have
in orbit
uh more than 180 of these sets so to
give you
a sense of the scale um how different
these ads are
to the rapid eye so the rapid eye are
like a mini fridge
uh and the doves are like a shoebox size
so
30 by uh by 10 centimeters um like yeah
then they're very small but they have um
very similar capabilities so they take
images
um what we call medium resolution so
that means
a pixel is equivalent to three meters
um something that will be three meters
on ground
um and then they they image the earth on
different
bands so there are the visual bands that
we see red green blue
and then additional bands that will help
us identify things like vegetation
yeah vegetation in this indices that
will help for
agriculture detection for example um
and then we have a constellation of high
resolution satellites these are
we currently have 21 in space and these
are about the same
size as the rabbit is also like a mini
fridge
but these ads have the capability of
taking like really high resolution
images so
um sub meter resolution um
okay so that's what we have on space so
it's like having all these cameras
around like orbiting the earth
um so what system do we need to
actually talk to the satellite and then
make sure that we are
getting health data from them and that
we are getting all those pictures that
they are taking down
um so this is in a nutshell what our
system looks like
um so there's the space segment so which
is all this group of satellites and then
we of course have radius on board of
them so that we can talk to
two ground stations on earth um and
because we have such a large number of
satellites
on space we also need a large number of
ground stations
on the ground so operations is not only
about taking care of the satellites that
are
on space but also taking care of the um
of the systems of ground that support
the space system um so
i'm gonna go into the detail on the
radio frequencies and all but there are
like
to simplify there are two types of
communication so a low speed one and a
high speed one so
with low speed communication we can get
health data from the satellites and
upload commands to them and with high
with high rate radius then we download
you know all the images which are um a
larger
amount of data um and then we need
systems that will
orchestrate how each of these resources
are used like
um to which satellites each antenna
talking how many times a day
uh what is each satellite doing on a
given day like where is it taking images
um when it's supposed to point to the
ground station to download data when
it's supposed to point to
to the ground and actually take a
picture um so those systems
are also built in house um so for us
so there is a scheduler that will make
sure to deconflict those resources
um there is mission control um you
probably
um have in mind the picture you know
like in the
latest um mars rover landing you see
like
a lot of monitors each of them
monitoring a subsystem
and then engineers behind them um
you know sending the commands and make
monitoring the telemetry that comes from
the spacecraft so
basically that's what mission control
does but in a different
setup so mission control for us is built
on the cloud
so um and it doesn't have a lot of
people sitting 24 7
in front of them to monitor the sets so
um that is possible because we
have a lot of automation in place and
i'm gonna elaborate more on that later
uh but just just to have the the the two
differences so
mission control for me is like now i'm
sitting at home in berlin and
i can access it through my laptop or
like from my couch
and then i can command the satellites
from there um
and then of course we need um
like a place where we store all the data
that comes down so we have
logs we have telemetry we have pictures
and we want to make sure that
all these systems are built such that we
can build on top of them
so that they all have endpoints that we
can query that data
with other scripts that will run on top
um so those were designed
from the very beginning with that in
mind um
yeah and then we have a different what
we call pipeline for for the images
uh that's different storage where each
of the pictures get
processed and there's some quality
checks in between all of that automated
because daily we have
daily we download more than 15 terabytes
of data
so we have to process all that data of
course
in a very automated way um yeah and then
once the images go through all that
processing pipeline and image quality
checks then they get published
and delivered on a platform that are
that our customers can
can access um
cool so how we do all of that and
of course this wasn't like the picture
at the beginning um
so we we use agile aerospace and
everything but
what does agile airspace mean so it's on
its core it's rapid iteration
um so on everything so from
manufacturing the satellites to
iterating quickly on the software the
satellites are running on the software
that we are running around
on how we do testing um so one good
example of
rapid iteration is um these doves
um it was actually not just one model
so we have had more than 13 iterations
over time and we are
past 13. um so what we do is
put some new components put the new
software um launch a new tech demo test
it on orbit and if that works then
that will become the next um the next
version to launch
so that's how we have been able to
progress very quickly and get like
always the latest and best packed into
this
three uni cubesat form uh over the years
um and that also that also happens on
on the software side so the way we we
process the data
from space operations space operations
point of view to now has changed
following that um that agile airspace
mentality
and a key part of this when trying to do
this um
it's also always building the tools with
that in mind
um with with having a sk
like a scalability online knowing that
okay now we are operating 20 sets but
in a year we might have 200 on orbit um
so that makes things easier and
makes the system um just robust
to handle what what comes on the road
map
um and i want to make a post um
talking about agile to um go to get into
something excited which is
this is also agile and so to have that
large number of satellites on the space
you need to
launch them uh and launchers are also
uh well no now the market is growing but
it's it's something
like constraints right there only enough
launchers in the world
so we need to make sure that um we are
launching as often as we need
um so this is just a snapshot of what
the year looked like
looked like for us like the last year um
so we had
uh lunches
okay thanks um yeah so we
launched from a european rocket the vega
there we had 26 of our newest doves
which we call super dops um and then
something interesting of that rocket is
we had two different deployers
so the satellites get deployed
from what we call uh quad quad pod so
it's basically like boxes with a spring
that
um release the sats but there were two
different
of those systems on board so that was
something new for us
um and then we launched six of our
high-resolution sky sets
um with spacex uh we actually had
yeah two spacex languages one electron
and one vega
actually two electrons um yeah so just
that's another part that is also agile
you know using as many opportunities as
we can to get
uh sats into space um and to give you an
idea of the amount of data that we have
to deal with
um the global ground station network um
last year collected over five petabytes
of data
um yeah and our most written launch was
actually on january
um i put this because this was very
exciting so it was a record-breaking
launcher you probably have seen um
i don't know if well i always see the
the live transmissions from any um
any rocket launch but this was a spacex
record-breaking one because this was
the most small sets ever launched all
together
so 143 satellites were put all together
on this rocket and they all
um had the same right um so here we
launched 48 super dopes um so
also on two different two different
deployers and this was our 30th
successful launch um so far and this is
one of the images that
um one of our sets that we're launching
that on that rocket
took right after being commissioned
cool now i'm going to talk about how
they operate so the concept of operation
so that you have an idea of
what we have to do as a space operations
than for automation
um so our doves um are a monitoring
mission
so monitoring means they are always
taking pictures
uh over landmass um because that's our
point of interest
um and then like if they are not taking
images then they are
talking to the ground stations and
downloading that data um and when they
are not doing either of those two things
um to be able to have them as a line
scanner separated like in the video we
need to phase them out
so space them out along the orbital
plane
and to do that we use um differential
drag maneuvers
so like the satellite will be rotating
so that um
the atmospheric drag will affect its
position in relation to the others and
they will slowly separate
uh among the plane so those three things
uh so it's pretty simple
um well it sounds simple um but yeah
that's basically what the sets uh have
to do and one important thing
to mention is like um we don't do 24 7
off so there's not a person there
looking what each satellite is doing all
the time
and that's because uh we have a lot of
automation in place
um so what we call nominal operations
is uh basically all the tasks to make
sure that the satellite is healthy
and it's doing what it's supposed to do
so for us that you know it's
it's able to take pictures and it's
taking pictures and it's able to
download them to the ground stations
and it's downloading them um so the
first
thing of all is like how do you tell the
satellite what to do um so there comes
the scheduler so the scheduler is
an optimizer building house that will
everyday um
you know score um
areas of the of the la of the landmass
that each of the satellite combat
can better take a picture of and then
like that
combined with the power budget of the
satellite we would just distribute
um images imaging activities we call
them so slots where the sets are taking
images
to each of them and to the whole
constellation and then based on like
how many pictures a satellite has taken
so it has a lot of other parameters and
then it optimized for
how to better distribute all the
available time
um that the ground stations have so the
scheduler will take care of doing that
autonomously and it runs daily
uh many times a day um so that's one
thing so there doesn't
we don't need an operator or a person
like deconflicting or creating
um schedules for the satellites um
yeah so that's very important also
important not only for the space segment
but also for the ground
um network so we have um
more than 40 antennas distributed across
the world so it will be just
unsustainable to have you know persons
dedicated on each of them
in each of the locations and also the
they have to act as a network
um and then we need to know how each of
the satellites are doing
so once they are talking to the ground
station that data will come down
and instead of like you know looking at
each of those
um each of that data and just to give
you an idea
um our ground stations run more than 2
000 passes a day
so yeah it needs to be automated
um and also the way the images are
processed so
um yeah so let me talk about
what are our tasks but i can go more
into detail on the automations
um so what's the space operation so from
the moment um
the satellites are manufactured on
ground and then they're put on a rocket
and then they are launched so as as soon
as they leave the deployer
of the rocket and they are in space and
that's where our task
starts um so we
as the space ops are responsible of the
commissioning of those stats
commissioning means
making sure that all the subsystems are
working as expected
um be tumbling the satellite so but they
are deployed
they are tumbling at the given rate so
we want to make sure that we have
um the attitude controlled um that we
check that the radius working and the
camera is working so all of that process
needs to be done for each of these
satellites um and as soon as we can
um so for that we have also built in
automations and
actually this last launch was one of our
best commissioning
process so we something that would take
in the past
um more than a week to do so
commissioning will last like per
satellite
about seven to ten days we managed to
achieve
that uh to reduce that to to less than
two days
and that's because we built in
automation on board and also on ground
um so once the satellites are
commissioned and they are starting to do
you know what they have to do taking
pictures and downloading uh
we move into a monitoring stage so we
have to monitor that
and not unexpected things are happening
that anomalies
are being resolved or are being caught
um and then at the same time
as part of our agile aerospace we will
continuously test things on orbit so
call them experiments or testings
so obviously we have testing on ground
so we have satellites on grounds where
we test things first but we also
testing some space so we have um
we call them canaries so they're like
the um
or staging stats that that's where we
will test something first to make sure
that
everything's fine and then roll to the
hopefully
um and then anomaly debugging of course
so when something comes up and we need
to fix it
we need to look into it but we are also
working towards making this more
autonomously
um then yeah software uh we continuously
update the software that is running on
board the satellite
um so that's a big part of testing on
ground and also testing on orbit
and then when the satellites reach their
end of life then there is a retirement
process
but it doesn't end there so once the
satellite is no longer
productive and we have had to retire it
there is a lot of data
from that satellite so from their whole
lifetime and that that data will help us
create models
degradation models or forecast models
um what to expect from next from next
generation satellites
all right so um moving into how space
operations change
uh with the amount of satellites um so
obviously some years ago
we had attend even um probably a bit
less now
of the of the amounts of satellites that
we have now um
although mission control was built in
for scalability there have been
already many iterations so
but the the principle the principle
feature was that we wanted to have a
mission control
that will be able to talk to the ground
stations and handle
um the communication with the satellites
on its own so
that was a key stepping stone um
and then the first satellites that we
launched um
were a way of us a way for us as a space
operations to learn
um you know like what data we should be
looking at
so basically gather operational
experience
um so initially what what our job looked
like was
going through uh reports so logs that
um capture things that were happening on
ground or things that were happening um
on board the satellite uh and then we'll
have some sort of
um scripting that will filter or group
things
um like similar warnings or similar
captures and then we'll
we'll have that summary per satellite
and then an operator
one of us will have to look it into each
of those alerts and then
understand or understand the root cause
and then come up with a mitigation
so we would look at that daily per set
but of course
as the number of sets increased that
became
unsustainable um yeah it was time
consuming
uh you need to evaluate every alert and
as we were constantly iterating there
were
new um new things or new features on the
satellite so
there were different performance value
across satellites and of course as the
number increased there was more data to
parse through
so um i remember there were days where
like it took us half a day of a working
day to go through
all of the alerts um and now it takes us
less than an hour
um so what changed so we had to move
from the uh traditional space operations
mentality of
let's look at what happens with each
individual set to
what do we expect from the whole fleet
um so we
shift that uh on our minds and say okay
let's first look at the value of the
constellation so
what is important is that as a whole as
a group these satellites have to deliver
this amount of data
and they have to download it within this
time
so what we look at now is
we build metrics with scripts
that will aggregate that data for us and
that will be the first indicator
if the fleet as a whole it's operating
as it should
um and then if not then we know there is
a fleet-wide issue
and then we have built alerting systems
for those metrics that matter the most
to us and we will only react to those
alerts then
and then the second layer is identifying
um the doves or the sets um on the fleet
that have some
non-nominal behavior but we don't want
to do that by looking at each of them
so what we want is for the metrics to
tell us
uh we expect this performance from this
ad
but there has been this deviation and
then we just want to see the alert
and we want to see the alert on the
specific thing that we have to look at
um so that's what we have now and then
the next step
is like okay now we know uh this alert
on this specific issue
has pop-up how do we mitigate this uh so
once we have the mitigation path we want
the next time this happens that we have
a script on top
we have a script that detects the issue
and then we have a script that
just applies the resolution
automatically so without us knowing but
of course we we want to have visibility
on how many times this happens so
we make sure to build metrics around
everything our automations
um on the performance um so by doing
this we optimize the system availability
and the capacity because
there is less engineering time spent at
looking at individual
things um investing in automation frees
up
a lot of our time on that and then makes
the responses
way quicker and so rather than a person
looking for something
and then some there's some delay time
between like okay coming up with the
response and applying the response
the um the automation is just taking
care of that
taking care of that immediately um so
that has been
that has been a great positive change um
so yeah i talk a lot about matrix um
so i mean this is a very simple diagram
of what we have in place
um as a space operations uh but it's
basically that
so we have the different entities of the
system so we have mission control
that has data from each of the
satellites and each of the ground
stations
uh we have orbit data from the sets we
have telemetry we have logs
and all of this data is stored in such
way that we can um
that we have endpoints to query that
data from so it's easy for us
to build a scripts on top um we use
python for this we have
a lot of um scripts that like a
group of them that we call mission
metrics that will tell us everything
from the high level
performance of the of the fleet to like
specific
um performance data per satellite and
per sub system
so it just gives us the granularity that
we need and also it abstracts
to um through high-level metrics
um and then we we can decide how to use
this data
that's the great thing so we can from
there
you know use those aggregated records
and then build automated responses
on top do analysis on python notebooks
or simply like display the data on
visual ways like
using tools like grafana or kibana
so it just is just like a very powerful
way of
using data analysis on any issue that
can come up
um yeah so over the years
and i would say especially the last two
years or so
um yeah the the role of the space ops
operator
uh has been taken over by the automation
so um we call it out the wall but it's
not
it's that's why the the logo here uh but
the automation has taken that role
uh so it takes care of the common
anomalies um and maximizes the
performance of the fleet um
cool and this is one a specific example
of one of the automations
uh this might be going into too much
detail and actually one of my colleagues
talked
about this specific use case on pi data
but more than a year ago now so
maybe it's time for us to do another
deep dive on this but
um this is just one clear example of
where automation is
is just very important um so
we use we use a job that sets that
on the duty cycle on each satellite
so the duty cycle is how many times in a
day
the satellite will spend imaging uh
the earth so it only can do so much
because there is only so
so much land to to take pictures of and
also because there's only so much power
um so the power depends uh because we
have solar panels
the power depends on um the sun and the
sun beta and also
across the stations in a year um that
angle changes
um so we want to make sure that our
power models and the duty cycle
includes that change so the lower the
rectangle the lower
illumination the panels have so
the lower the the power it's available
to the satellite so we want to make sure
that we know that and the satellite
knows that
so that it's not overdoing itself like
it's not trying to take more pictures
with the power that it doesn't have
um so this is obviously um
it's it will make sense to do this
manually and like checking
every time of the year when we have to
change this so basically that's what an
automation is doing is just
um checking the power telemetry saying
okay this
the the voltages on board look look okay
if there is a dip
and a flag has trigger on the power
system then it will say oh you are doing
you're doing much more than what you
need to do so let's reduce your duty
cycle
so it's doing that tuning for us and by
doing that we are keeping the satellite
healthy and we are also making sure that
when we have a lot of power we are
imaging as much as we can
and when not we are dialing dialing it
back
um cool so yeah that's just one example
of
the many things that we have to control
but uh that are just made easy by having
uh ready available metrics that we can
aggregate in any way we can
um yeah and then build on top of that
so what's next um so we have reached
that point where we feel comfortable
with
um you know like the the the detection
and mitigation
and the metrics that we have uh and now
we are trying to explore with
machine learning applications so we have
all these data
already aggregated in many ways um
so what we are trying to discover is how
we can um
make make use of that historical data
altogether um
so what we have in mind like
maybe in the long term it's being able
to predict the anomalies
so we know some signatures we have the
data
of all the subsystems and we we also
have operator data
when an anomaly has happened like as an
operator as a human hub what
what are the things you have to look at
um so training the
training those data sets with that um
might help us um be more predictive uh
and also
predict uh performance degradation so we
know okay
um we have a better model for
forecasting
uh and eventually um just
having an autonomous fleet um that
requires no human in the loop
um that's like the ultimate goal but um
yeah we're not there yet but those are
some next steps
um cool and i wanted to learn because i
talked a lot about space and launches
but
um why is this important so abstracting
a bit from the technical side of things
um and actually these are some
applications that you know where
python or um any type of data analysis
is super powerful
uh it's to play not play but to actually
use the data that comes down from the
satellites
um so to me this is a very oops sorry
this is a very powerful video that
shows what can be observed um so this is
data from
um this is an image from the amazon
forest
from 2017 uh till last year
so because we have daily images you can
see how things change
across time um
yeah so it's just uh i think it's just
powerful and it's something um
that adds this visibility that we didn't
have before um
yeah you can see the deforestation
how it's increasing across the days
yeah it's very sad but yeah
this is a really good example of the
impact that our data can make
and of the applications of earth
observation imagery in general
um cool thanks um of course
uh there's some time for questions i
think i might have extended myself a bit
but
if you are excited about what we do
about space
anything space operations data analytics
um you know we are hiring a lot so check
out our career pages
or let me know if you want to know more
thanks
thanks a lot katya was very interesting
i'm biased okay
um we'll do
[Music]
or noah a me with the questions we have
questions both in
youtube and i guess here
i please write your question in the chat
if you have any um we have a question
from youtube which
uh what is the lifespan of these
satellites from large to their
retirement
yeah so the design life is up to three
years
but we have definitely seen cells that
have
lived more than that
thanks i see a question are there
images available to the public
um there are two different programs so
just recently we signed
an agreement with the norway government
it's called nifky
so that's opening data for forests
around the world
so there are there are different ways
where the data can be shared
i encourage you to visit our website for
more info
another one yes assuming this is open
data are you tracking who is using these
images will be nice to see the
applications
um well for the we definitely have a
research program
where universities do different um
studies and like applications with our
data and those are
available through paper and scientific
publications
um i'm not sure if we have that um it's
like listed or grouped on our website
but i'm sure if you
um search for that on the internet just
papers and
scientific publications you will find uh
some of them
not many of them
um
controlling a world satellite fleet from
a couch is awesome but does it bring
additional security risks
yeah of course um our um security team
make sure that
you know there are all the um security
measures in place so that we can
be able to do this so it's not as easy
as
going to the website for instance but
they make our systems easy
to work with for us
cool um i think there is no more
oh no yeah there's no other
so thanks again katya it was very
interesting
thanks valentina thanks everyone for
inviting me
thank you uh i think we will have a
five-minute break it's for someone who
needs to
i don't know go to the bathroom or
whatever
and then we will proceed yeah so
uh right now it's uh 7 47
so let's meet in let's keep it round
let's meet in 55
if it's okay so you can all grab a beer
if you want
or soda or toilet or
kebab
whatever you want
okay
does someone has a joke a joke
now on
okay so because when pi data
i have to use pi joke which is the pip
library that you can install
so how to explain the movie inception to
a programmer
when you run a vm inside another vm
inside another vm everything runs
really slow
still two minutes i really
really advise to install this library
really useful
okay last one before we go
um the child dad why does the sun
rise in the east and set in the west
dad sun it's working don't touch it
that was better almost funny
i do my best okay
55
so i think we can start
so let's uh work on for the second patch
um with niladri
who will talk about an overview of deep
fakes
so he is working as a data scientist at
sentinel
uh where he works with government and
security agency to defense again deep
fakes
and information welfare so
nerdery you're done
you you are muted
we don't hear you for the moment yes uh
sorry yeah
uh can you hear me now
yes okay great uh
hello um good evening everyone and
thanks to by the berlin for having me
today i'll be talking about defects or
why i have trust issues
so let's begin
so one thing i've heard and sure all of
you have heard as well is that a picture
is worth a thousand words
but what if that picture is actually
fake so then what does it say
it turns out it actually sees more and
based on whom and
where you ask it could contain a lot of
misinformation
so let's look at this picture and this
picture is
looks very much like a human but it's
completely fake
and it's been generated by an ai program
uh so if you look at this website called
this person does not exist.com
so like every time you go there it will
generate a fake image
and uh turns out that there are a ton of
these sites
and based on what you like i'm sure
there's something for everyone
starting from this this meme does not
exist the startup does not exist and
also
for cat fans this cat does not exist
you know that's where my trust issues
you know time to
you know begin so let's look at this uh
defect which has been circulated
by uh you know it's coming very popular
this month and it's a defect of tom
cruise
so
it's a little uh embarrassing you know
it reminds me i was once in
russia i ran into uh gorbachev
he said yummy standard movie star
are you nervous tick tock
you guys cool if i play some sports
as you can see like this is the
statement
in 2021 uh this is what you can do
but it's not all fun because defects
caused a lot of problems
and there was this incident where a
journalist was
investigating or rather exposing a sex
child
sorry child sex abuse case and
to silence her they started with the
misinformation campaign
about some fake tweets and uh when she
didn't stop so they launched a
defect porn offer and that
uh kind of had a very uh you know big
big effect on her and starting with
discrediting her as a journalist and
it ended quite badly and this is
not that uncommon so
uh you can see a lot of these defects uh
being used
to essentially uh alter public opinion
starting with a defect of belgian
premier talking about that uh climate
crisis is imminent
and linking that to covet and we also
have other cases where in india
there was a bgp leader there was a
political party
trying to reach out to their voters in
their local language and the
audio was generated uh was uh used by
uh was generated by nai and
uh right now the uh like before the
entry to use
the rather the entry barrier to use the
fake technology
was kind of like only like the
experts could use it let's say but that
has been going down
so we have been seeing the rise of uh
defects
as a technical barrier to creating them
goes down
so right now the true estimation is uh
around 100 million plus defects
in 2021 and a lot of them have to do
with the easy to use
apps so there is this very popular app
called
reface uh you might have heard of it uh
it actually was trending at one point uh
like it was
trending at uh number one in
entertainment it also beat tiktok
so it allows you to uh to easily create
defect videos
and uh this was a news article which i
read yesterday
it was a mother uh using defeat to
actually frame her daughter's uh rivals
that
uh they were doing uh like essentially
create a fake video of their rivals so
it's as you can see it's no longer you
know just being used for to defame
uh celebrities or used to for political
agendas
it could the next victim could be you or
me so this is
has like probably like right now is like
the tipping point
so the cost of this information annually
as estimated in 2019
it was around 78 billion and uh
the most alarming thing is that fall
stories actually reach
six times faster compared to true
stories
so the uh the infiltration if you launch
a defect
is much faster so now let's look at a
few types of defect
so the first one is face swapping so
what happens is that you have a source
phase
which is original and the target phase
and
the bi model kind of learns what are the
facial features of the source and the
target
are and essentially swaps these and
creates a super imposition to
manipulate a face swap defect
and then you have the second type which
is facial reenactment
so what happens is that uh you have the
source video
and uh and the target so uh
you can like for example make uh facial
movements or speak anything you want
and that will kind of be mimicked on the
target phase so
you could make any person say anything
that you want
and this is kind of a pretty dangerous
right
uh you can also have full body defects
where you essentially move the target's
entire body to whatever pose you like
and then the fourth category of course
which is audio defect
uh where you can generate uh an audio
which has been uh
like may make a person's voice so there
was this case where
a company ceo was uh so
a defect of the company ceo was used to
mimic a wire transfer
of around 243 000
and this has been a rising problem
so let's look at this video i'm not
going to say to you if this is uh
fake or real uh let's see how you can
probably
look at this when mexico sends its
people they're not sending their best
they're not sending you they're not
sending you
they're sending people that have lots of
problems
and they're bringing those problems with
us
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime
they're rapists so uh
maybe you know if you've seen this uh if
it's
fake or not or real so and that's you
you know where the
trust issue really starts to begin where
you even start to doubt
what's a real video and you think
probably that's a fake
so it's kind of uh well buyers dividend
that we have when mexico sends
its people they're not sending
and the trust issues start to increase
and
probably like to the moon so
there was uh this
report published by a republican hub
republican candidate
and he claimed that uh the george
floyd's death incident was
completely fake and uh digitally
manipulated using effect
now that's of course uh false but
uh it's that just because you
there like just because defect exists it
kind of puts
into jeopardy the entire uh like
a real video might be called as you know
it's defect it doesn't exist
you probably just created it
so uh some of the trust issues are like
uh you know
defects can be used to uh cause fraud uh
espionage inside mental or physical harm
like we saw
in case of the uh journalist and we have
been
seeing uh increase in uh these kind of
crimes uh particularly against women
where someone's uh sales are rather
blackmailed
that a person's defeat porn might be
used and uh
there are of course other uh aspects to
it like uh influencing judicial
proceedings to the point of actually
threatening national integrity and
security
so what does what does the future hold
uh
so now right now we have ai generated
uh text so like there's a very popular
model called gpt3
which can be used to generate any kind
of text that you want
and now you have uh defects to generate
any kind of video
or gangs to generate any kind of image
so
you essentially have all the tools to
generate whatever event you want and you
can do that at scale
and thus you can manipulate opinion and
essentially spread this information
so how does defect work so
uh one of the most popular approaches
used in defect is
by using something called as auto
encoders so in an auto encoder
architecture there is typically three
blocks
so one is the encoder uh one is the
bottleneck and you have the decoder
so the encoder's job is essentially to
encode information
uh like an image which is a high it's a
high dimensional
representation into a low representation
or rather encoded which is stored in the
bottleneck and the decoder decodes that
information again to that previous
image so usually the decoder just
reconstructs the
tries to reconstruct that input now with
the
auto encoders you can do multiple things
and one of them is
you can create uh fake images or
anything you want
so how can you use enco auto encoders to
uh you know essentially create defects
is that you have this encoder block
which is uh kind of uh shared so uh
we'll actually need two uh auto encoders
for uh creating defects
so uh so the first part is uh the top
part which you see
is the source image and the bottom
is the target so the source image is uh
you could be yourself and the target is
that whatever you want to impose
uh like a target person let's say you
want to swap
uh donald trump's image on alec baldwin
so alec wildman here is the target and
donald trump here is the source
so uh in this architecture the encoder
is actually
is the same for both the source and the
target
and we have two separate decoders
so uh for the source
input we going to encode it and again
decode it exactly
uh to donald trump's uh image and
for the um target we are going to do the
same
and this is what happens in the training
part and when you want to actually
generate uh
the the let's say a defect what you're
going to do is
let's say use the encoder part for uh
for donald trump's image and use the
decoder part for
alex baldwin's so what you have uh here
is that
by using a diff like the source from the
encoder and the decoder part for the
targets you'll essentially
kind of scrap uh the faces now
uh this is not exactly like
state-of-the-art stuff because uh
there's a lot of artifacts usually
present and with the previous approach
uh you will need like pairs of uh videos
so
it would require a lot of training and
you can't exactly
use that uh for like inference or like
testing whenever you want
so you will need a lot of data to create
someone's defect
but technology has been improving since
then so you have this uh something
an architecture called as fa scan which
is kind of subject agnostic
and what that means is that you do not
uh need
uh you know a pairwise training so
so if you do not have a source uh on a
target video
uh um like a training data of it so
uh you can still use this because uh
when you actually want to use this uh
sort of architecture to create your own
defect you do not need
to gather a lot of data and need pairs
of source image and target video
so how does this work is by using
something called as a generative
adversarial network
uh the way it works is that you have two
blocks essentially one is the generator
and another is the discriminator
the generators essentially creates
no fake images and the discriminator's
job is to
try to differentiate between the real
images and
fake images and the discriminator does
this really well at first
but ultimately the generator actually
manages to fool the discriminator
into thinking that the fake image is a
real image
and by generating these kind of uh
you know this sort of a training
procedure
we are actually able to create uh fake
images which are very
uh lifelike uh such kind of sort of the
stuff that you saw in the beginning
uh where we where i showed you an image
of a fake person so how does this work
in f scan
is that for example if you have the
source
and you have the target uh what you
calculate first is
kind of like landmarks so these so these
would be guiding face landmarks so a
landmark is essentially
what you see on the left over here and
uh so
it contains uh you know points to uh
your face uh and it picks out like uh
very specific uh and important features
of your face which
can be used to represent so
in this first part you have these guys
sort of guiding face landmarks
and this will be used uh to kind of
uh first uh be passed to a generator to
first of all
align this uh source phase into sort of
the way the target space
is uh looking at so so the first thing
which happens over here is
the post correction and over here
uh the target space will be uh passed uh
another generator which kind of
separates uh all these
uh like separates the various uh parts
of the face
so you have the face separated out and
the other parts of the image will be
again separated out like the hair or a
earring or something like that
and then essentially uh we'll be
kind of using the landmarks which we got
to essentially train our generator
to uh essentially make uh
generate images uh or essentially gets
us sort of like how the movement of the
face is uh working
so we have multiple images so if it's a
video
we can extract multiple frames and we'll
get
a lot of these uh landmarks so that's
why you have multiple landmarks
and once and and if you interpolate
between them
um you can get an idea of how
to move the source or rather than
to move the object object so uh kind of
the sources source's face in a way the
target's face is moving
and once you have that you can do
something called as in painting so
typically
uh once we have this image you can see
like a lot of parts on this image are
kind of
not completed and this is very typical
because you always have partial
occlusions
and that can be filled up by an in
painting
network which essentially
fills up this image by picking up detail
from
the target face so whatever uh you know
missing features are from the source
you can probably pick it up on the
target's face and create something and
complete this image
and the last part is the blending part
where the source
uh space is so you know really blended
well
to the target space to the point of
looking like uh you know very real life
like
and uh this is uh open source so you can
try this out
it's present in the github repository of
the paper
which is called fsgan and they also have
a collab notebook
so you can try it out really fast
so let's look at how you can actually
spot a fake image
and this will be a manual procedure so
over here we can see a
image and this was released by north
korea's
central news agency and they were trying
to
show a military exercise where north
korea's
hovercraft sorry hovercrafts uh were
landing on the east coast so and over
here you can see it like
they have multiple hovercrafts here and
it's actually a fake image so over here
if you see
uh this uh left
block and if you compare it with the
right block you'll see that it looks
exactly similar so this was essentially
a copy paste
of the of this object
over here and similarly if you look at a
few finer details like
this ship uh you will notice that uh
there is uh no wake compared to this
ship where you can see that there's week
so things of uh you know
small details and also like um
essentially that uh
some an image will obviously not violate
the laws of physics
you can probably understand uh that an
image is fake
and then there are other things which
you can look at for example um
the temperature the weather data uh if
the time
if the image showcases a particular time
stamp you can probably even see
like uh the sunlight direction where it
is coming from
and so the shadows will actually show
that
and this is a demonstration of how a
copy of an object can be copy pasted
elsewhere and
uh over here you can see that this
hovercraft we can copy and again paste
it here
and that essentially showcases a lot of
military strength
kind of to mislead other countries
but this is something which can't be
done
right now because this is kind of if you
see
for example the first video of which i
showed you of
uh of tom cruise uh it's really
difficult to detect defect so uh
but there's a problems and so we have a
solution as well and the first is that
we can use an image based model and so
you have this
uh input video you're going to extract
that into frames
and then you're going to uh get uh
like extract the face from that uh frame
so
uh if you look at the entire image it
might not convey a lot of information
and uh it's may not be that useful
so if it's a difficult video uh the
typically the part which is manipulated
is the face itself so
it's better to just look at the face and
then you can
uh use face alignment techniques to
essentially
rotate that face uh somewhat so that
it's always straight it just helps
the classifier and then you're going to
pass that to a 2d cnn
a cnn is a neural network architecture
specifically suited for image tasks so
you can use an architecture like resnet
or an efficient net
and then you can finally make a
prediction
and this uh so you will get a prediction
for every frame in that video
and then you can use some kind of coding
strategy to
get your final prediction of the entire
video
then you can also use video based models
so
in the previous approach we used
an image based so that we were using two
dc engines
you can also use a 3d cnn and what does
that what
that does is essentially looks at both
aspects which is special and temporal
so it kind of processes the entire video
at
one go and you can since it's also
looking at the temporal aspect so if
there are
artifact you know disappearing and
appearing in the next frame or something
like that
uh small changes can also be caught by
the classifier
now a defect detection challenge was
hosted on
kaggle uh so it was uh hosted by
facebook amazon and uh microsoft
and uh and one trend was that the
like all the top performing solutions uh
they
didn't use digital forensic methods like
sensor noise uh fingerprints
which uh can extract a lot of uh
information from
uh image creation like you know when you
create an image it
uh kind of has a lot of information but
if you let's say copy paste an
uh an object which like we saw uh it
will add its own
uh fingerprint noise and that can be
easily picked up
so for example uh we have a real face
and the top and the fake face at the
bottom and if you do
uh noise level analysis uh since this uh
photo has been like kind of like
essentially a face map
the part of the face which was swapped
and blended you can see
uh the the noise level analysis which
kind of revealed that
and uh and it's the same with error
level
analysis as well so this can be kind of
uh used to detect uh defects as well
so the there's this paper called face
x-ray for more uh general phase forged
detection
and the good thing is that you don't
need uh
any kind of uh defect data set to begin
with
so all it needs is real face uh real
face uh faces
and uh it kind of generates uh fake
faces on its own
by essentially uh blending those faces
uh we talked about uh landmarks before
and the way it uh creates its own sort
of fake faces is by
it picks up a random image it will uh
calculate its landmarks and it will look
for
uh in in the data set we'll look for its
closest
uh pair of image which also says similar
landmarks
and it just um kind of blends those
images
and uh so what happens is that you you
created this
fake image and you also created the
blending mask so the blending mask is
where
these two sort of faces got blended so
that you have the background face and
the foreground face
and wherever the part of the image the
both the
images were kind of blended you get that
final mask and so
so you have a pair of mask
for every fake image that you create and
and essentially if you have a real image
you do not have a face mask
if it's a fake image you have a face
mask so
essentially what you can do is image
segmentation so
an image segmentation is essentially
splitting an entire frame
into and drawing like a sort of a
an overlay over each and every object
which is different from each other
so for example over here you can see a
human with a type of overlay and a
different overlay
on vehicles for example so
since now we have uh created our own
data set
so keep in mind that our own data set a
fake
a fake image will have this sort of a
blending mask and a real face
won't show any blending mask so
essentially you're going to try to
predict where that image
uh has been blended and you can do this
using
a kind of a unit like architecture
where you have uh down sampling and an
up sampling network
so uh the final prediction is a fake
image if
the architecture detects that there is a
blending mask and if it's not a blending
mask
if there is no blending mask it
essentially means that
the image is real
then you can also for example look at a
video metadata to essentially
detect if a video is fake and
for this approach you do not need uh
to look at the pixel level what you
instead going to look at is stream
descriptors
so every video sort of has some metadata
associated with it and even if some of
the metadata tags are missing
you can use something like ff pro to
extract
all uh like metadata possible from the
video
so and once you gather all these
metadata and
it contains things like what codec it is
using time base
fps whatever codec it is using audio
protect
and so on and so forth and whenever
a video is kind of manipulated some of
these stream descriptors change
and it changes in a way which is not
kind of
correlated or constant with the real
videos
so by essentially looking at uh the
stream descriptors
you can detect if a video has been
manipulated or not
and another strategy is to look at
semantic integrity
and that one what that means is you're
going to look at particular features in
an image
so if
you're given an image uh you can
calculate a lot of stuff from by looking
at its metadata
uh things like gps and time so
you know uh the weather data uh
corresponding to a particular time in a
particular
gps location and you can gather all
the weather data from it like sun angles
temperature humidity
and weather information and you can also
train
a neural network uh to detect all these
things on its own
so just by looking at an image you can
you want to train a neural network to
estimate all these values
so and then you can compare can you sort
of compare
uh the sun angle calculated by the
neural network and the sun
angle which uh which the weather data
shows
and uh if there is a difference between
these two
you can say that this is a fake if
it is kind of the same it essentially
tells that uh it's a real image
and the last thing which you can do is
sort of an audio analysis
so there is something called a
spectrogram a spectrogram can be
generated from raw audio by
taking its uh fourier transform or
wavelet transform
things of that nature so you have this
raw audio signal and
you can calculate its uh spectrogram and
then
kind of train a neural network to detect
like fake and real videos just by
looking at the spectrogram
so the spectrogram is a kind of has very
i sort of put you know peculiar features
when
audio is generated by ai and by looking
at these kind of features you can
predict uh whether the audio is fake or
not
uh so our deep fake detection pipeline
at sentinel
particular has been you know kind of
modeled after cyber security standard of
defense in depth
and so we have multiple kind of neural
networks looking at various features
uh starting from metadata to semantics
uh
integrity and like uh just uh image
and video based methods and also look at
the
audio now defects
aren't all bad they have their own good
use cases as well which was
kind of well they were invented in the
first place
for example you can bring old memories
to life
over here you can use an app called deep
nostalgia
which has been vogue of late so it kind
of
uh animates a a picture
you can take like any old photograph you
have and it will sort of
you know animate animated which is kind
of
really nice
also like for example if you want to
hide your digital identity
you can do that so there was this
documentary shot
of uh anonymous uh survivors of
the lgbtq plus uh community and uh
the this community was in chechnya and
they
did not want to reveal their identities
so some volunteers uh
appeared and they kind of some people
volunteered to
allow their face to be swapped on these
faces of the survivors to anonymize
them
you also have a lot of interesting use
cases in hollywood for example
so there was you can see the screenshot
of the film the irishman and over here
robert de niro and al pacino's uh you
know
faces were kind of de-aged and typically
this requires
a lot of first of all a lot of money
and a very big va vfx studio
and this is kind of a bottleneck
if uh an indie producer or a small scale
production house wants to
do these kind of uh you know apply these
kind of vfx technologies
but with defects this barrier is kind of
lowered a lot
so there goes uh to democratizing
hollywood
and of course you can improve your
virtual interactions
by uh animating your digital avatar
so i generated this avatar from a
website called ready blur me
and then you can kind of animate this
face
uh into the way you want to talk so it
kind of improves your
virtual interactions uh in the age of
digitization and with that
i would like to wrap up my talk and
thank you for coming to my pi data talk
i'll be taking questions
[Applause]
okay uh
we have one question uh from dimitris
uh does the fs can generate
ships too no it's just for the face
right
yeah it's only for our faces so like
defect
we have a question from valley but
i think it's missing some context
how about audio was using what data can
you elaborate on that
uh so if you have like audio clippings
of
uh real and like fake uh audio like you
can like train
a neural network on it uh like the first
step you need to do is to
essentially get a spectrogram of that
audio clip and then
just look at this spectrogram so that be
done by a neural network
great
any other questions oh yes
uh okay a question from stephen uh
will the detection method you talked
about distinguish
between deep fake and more com more
cosmetic
or artistic changes
sorry i'm not sure to understand the
question
uh so somehow if the data is kind of you
know labeled
as a defect it will only like detect if
there's a defect so you have like
cosmetic changes
it won't be picked up but if you train a
classifier to particularly look at uh
you know cosmetic changes then it will
be picked up
[Music]
we have a question from alti is there a
large-scale demand for detecting deep
fakes or
other than other than cases such as
google facebook or social media
uh yeah so apart from you know big
companies uh
there is also like governments and
security agencies
which need it so for example darpa which
is the r d bing
of the united states of america they
have
been had they have a lot of funding and
they are trying to detect
defects and essentially any kind of wiki
manipulation
uh that's another question from
fushira uh how do you know which portion
of a picture frame to check for
um so the procedure is like you pass in
the entire video
so and then you can like split that
video into frames
and every frame is going to be checked
and now if your question is to deal like
which portions of a particular frame
that you want to look at
so so typically in a defect
you know video the part which is
manipulated is the face
so you can just crop out the face and
then you can
like like look at like particular
features
so and the way you can extract faces
from a
frame is by sorry
by using some sort of a phase detector
so something like mpcnn
would work
great um
i can see that there's a question if uh
defects are getting harder to detect
yeah
and uh yes it is it's always kind of
like a cat and mouse game
where the detectors beat the generators
and the generators then again
beat the detectors so we have to improve
our detection methods
and as you notice like we have like
there are a lot of ways
how you can detect so and if you
kind of utilize multiple methods it kind
of
gets very hard for the generators to
essentially
make sure that all of these kind of
features are taken into account when
they're generating
great i think we did
all the question uh if you have any more
uh if you have more questions
we can all meet in wonder
so we talk at the start uh this is
basically a
platform um to
be able to interact in smaller group to
have a kind of a more meetup
like feeling so you will be able to
create small group and have a chat about
whatever you want uh so but
i will so um
thank you again nyadri uh for your talk
it was really interesting
uh i will stop recording and the
live on youtube on youtube if you want
to join
you can also go to the meetup page
uh on the pi data
pi data chapter go to the meetup and
you will have the link to the wonder if
you want to join from there
okay i will